let's go to our next caller from the
8:00 to 8:00 area code caller from 8:00
to 8:00 who's this hiya David this is
journey thither Lane from Asheville
North Carolina what's going on journey
love your show and my concerns I've been
watching I used to be a Green Party
delegate okay I don't want to get into
that I know what that sounds alright I
hope that's getting to get into all of a
sudden okay fine I go ahead was a Green
Party volunteered for the Green Party
since 1991 in 2016 I I was elected Green
Party delegate that same year in
Buncombe County the Green Party was of
Buncombe County which is in Asheville
North Carolina was disbanded during a
crucial election year that upset me it
was against my vote I continued to
collect put petition signatures because
here in North Carolina we needed ballot
access I collected over 5,000 signatures
for ballot access we got ballot access
and then as soon as we got ballot access
in North Carolina certain high-ranking
members or people actually I didn't know
to start with but there were people in
the Green Party I'm concerned of
infiltration they seem to take over and
go against Green Party values making it
basically impossible for people in
poverty to join the Green Party how did
they do that
let's Ernie if we if I may yes sir if we
can slow it down just a little bit this
wasn't the subject I was realizing that
maybe the Green Party thing was not what
I would I anticipate it let's what was
your original reason you called in well
just let me close out that I do still
support the Green Party I felt that
there was some kind of infiltration okay
I'm happy to talk to you about that at
another time it is there interesting
story fair enough what I was interested
in and it does it is relative to what I
started with there my concerns from
watching politics for a long time and
YouTube and Facebook I had to leave
Facebook be
because of how controlled it was I'm
currently on YouTube and have been
watching it intently for quite a long
time there is so much control and I see
the repression
I see voter suppression I see the issues
coming up and then the Republicans
turning around and playing the victim
while they're actually imposing quite a
bit of that control it seems a deep end
subject that Alex Jones might touch on
multiple forms of mind control we don't
have to get into that hold on please
please please if let let me at least ask
some questions when I find that there
might be something interesting because
this is a very very long setup for a
question that I'm not sure if we're ever
gonna get when you talk about the mind
control techniques that are in play what
are those multiple forms who's doing
well that is such a long subject for
simple reflection on that subject I'm
concerned about about the suppression of
the vote and stealing of the elections
okay but but I'm asking what are the
forms of mind control ways for people to
see the proof for themselves is on
social media is on YouTube is through
the avenues of media that are
potentially controlled but at the same
time here's the good news
we've come a long way and there's a lot
of room for more journey journey if I
may and I'm yes we're getting sort of to
where I'm not sure how much further we
can go what would be an example of a
form of mind control through social
media well pick a platform basically
answer the question Facebook
I personally spent a long time there
posting many many videos I supported the
Green Party at that time I saw the way
the entire platform was set up was there
to wrangle people away from certain
subjects I'd like to get into specifics
but it's a longer
recession YUM and it's the easiest thing
for people to see for themselves it's
the hardest thing for people to believe
when so and rightfully so when somebody
else tells them this is the issue and I
everybody called out the election yeah I
apologize we're not able to go further I
really do appreciate the call I think I
definitely provided enough time to sort
of get a sense of that